hey guys GS news is back in Sydney this
week and a big thank you to those of you
who joined us throughout a mad week of
e3 reporting is the gaming news that
mattered for you Tuesday Bungie have
told kotaku why the ex destiny expansion
rise of iron will only be arriving on
ps4 and xbox one creative lead
Christopher Barrett and marketing
director Eric Osborne explained their
decision to move away from the last gen
consoles by saying in order to add more
stuff we would have had to remove stuff
from the game to still support legacy
content so leaving 360 and ps3 behind
allows us to make the bucket bigger and
there are new bells and whistles and fun
features we can do to be clear we're not
turning any of the old stuff off you can
still play destiny if you're sitting on
your 360 and you've just picked up the
taken king the pair added that the new
plague lands area which is set on earth
will be separate from the other Earth's
own the Cosmodrome Destiny's rise of
iron expansion will be up on sep tember
20 next up new details have arrived
about the upcoming spider-man game from
insomniac Phil Rosmah from Marvel and
insomnia crying into her explained on
Playstations III show that the game is
not tied to next year spider-man
homecoming film they've said the game
will have an all new story and world and
hopes to both respect the traditions of
the franchise while mixing things up
insomniac have said they've been given a
large amount of freedom to do what they
want with the massive brand as with the
game play into her explained we're going
to push spider-man in some areas whether
it's traversal whether it's fighting
whether it's just open world exploration
peter is a really smart guy how does
that tie into his life not just as Peter
Parker but when he brings his
intelligence to the fight additionally
insomniac confirmed that the spider-man
announcement trailer which we saw at e3
was recorded in game and in real time on
the existing ps4 and not the upcoming
more power
near model finally God of War director
Corey Barack has told Spanish gaming
site level up the pannu game will not
include multiplayer multiplayer was a
feature that was introduced previously
in god of war ascension but it didn't
receive a very positive reception VAR
log added that the upcoming god of war
also will not be kratos his last game
and that his son Charlie nor as kratos
is a demigod but isn't aware of his
father's past level up has reported that
the game will run at 30 frames per
second and GameSpot have contacted Sony
to confirm that one I me know down in
that comment box if you're excited for
god of war and we should head to
gamespot where we've got stories on
battlefield 4 DLC that you can pick up
for free and GTA Online's new mode
that's everything I've got for you today
but to join me again a bunch more news